we've got clouds out there we're going
for showers and thunderstorms as we
finish off the week right now
temperatures in the warm upper 80s dew
points
will be on the rise as we get through
our day and especially into tonight and
friday
31 humidity that's not too bad sunrise
was 5 46
7 48 the sunset so we're going to be
looking for a hot date 105
clouds and sunshine and a slight chance
of some isolated thunderstorms in the
afternoon
but that monsoon moisture will be
pushing back our way
especially into tonight and on into
friday and saturday
do want to update you there was a large
earthquake
off the coast of alaska in dillingham
alaska last night before midnight and
8.2 the strongest one they've had up
there
since the mid-1960s there were tsunami
warnings that were issued and
people urged to get to higher ground and
even a tsunami watch all the way down to
hawaii
but that was canceled during the
overnight hours really large 8.2 all
right we've got low pressure that's
moving out of texas across the desert
headed for southern nevada and this is
what's going to be the instigator to
push that monsoon back our way
also it will work against a low off the
southern california coast
kind of putting a squeeze play on us
here in southern nevada it's going to
bring moisture from the east
and also an influence from the west with
extra
energy and that's what's going to help
bring substantial moisture into our area
and a good chance of area-wide
thunderstorms
which could bring heavy rain in some
areas again and maybe lead
to some flash flooding showers right now
over interstate 40 around flagstaff
and last night we saw some passing
showers over the valley
very light a lot of that was cloud cover
but there were some very light light
showers around
so a slight chance of thunderstorms
today better chance
overnight and then more than 50 percent
chance
both friday and saturday again there's a
really good chance that your
neighborhood is going to get some rain
and it might be a lot of rain
in a short amount of time so flash
flooding very possible friday and
saturday
really have to be careful and watch out
if you're going to be outdoors slight
chances left for sunday
next week sunny drier and hot
107 109 later next week